[Inaudible babble]
90 minutes before the vice presidential debate even got started,
the GOP mistakenly tweeted and posted an article saying that
Mike Pence had clearly won.
That tells you everything you need to know about tonight's debate
and you didn't need to watch it.
What we need more than ever in American politics
are not politicians that simply talk over each other
and trod out scripted one-liners
that would have been tired in a 90s sitcom.
Do you want a "you're hired" president in Hillary Clinton
or a "you're fired" president in Donald Trump?
[Applause]
We need different points of view
and we need more voices on the stage.
And if we don't get that,
it's not going to get any better than this:
You whipped out that Mexican thing again.
For Reason TV, I'm Nick Gillespie.